it's also an uncertain christmas
financially for millions of americans
with unemployment benefits
set to run out tomorrow congress did
pass a coveted relief bill this week
but president trump opposes it paula
reed is near mar-a-lago where the
president is spending christmas and
paula a very merry christmas to you
thanks for working
a good morning and merry christmas to
you too jamie that stimulus bill was
actually flown down here to florida for
the president to sign
if he wants to but he's previously
threatened to veto the bill unless
payments to individuals are tripled
and yesterday house republicans rejected
an effort by democrats
to increase those payments from 600 to 2
000 and now members of both parties are
just calling on the president
to sign the bill as is yesterday the
president and the first lady they
released a holiday video but
made no mention of this economic relief
but the president did refer to the
coronavirus vaccine as a
christmas miracle now while the
president is down here in florida he has
no official events
on his calendar though it does say he'll
be taking meetings and
calls but the white house has not
provided any information about who he'll
be talking with or what they'll be
talking about
and yesterday the only time we saw the
president publicly
was when his motorcade pulled into his
golf club down here
today jamie we do not expect to see the
president all right paula thank you